[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend der blick in
unsere welt verstört vermutlich geht es
ihnen ähnlich da kommt im moment
ziemlich viel auf einmal auf uns zu und
das ist mehr als ein pessimistischer
eindruck der krieg gegen die ukraine
ohnehin furchtbar genug wirkt jetzt auch
noch die gefahr dass europas größtes
atomkraftwerk beschossen wird auf der
anderen seite der welt droht pekings
machthaber den menschen in taiwan
regelmäßige manöver an ein militärischer
konflikt der beiden weltmächte usa und
china ist nicht mehr wirklich
ausgeschlossen und von den verwerfungen
die uns allein die klimakrise bescheren
wird habe ich noch gar nicht gesprochen
jahrzehntelang hat gerade deutschlands
wirtschaft gut gelebt in und von einer
immer enger vernetzten welt mit billiger
energie aus russland produzierte autos
die dann in china einen lukrativen
absatzmarkt finden sind nur ein beispiel
nichts weniger als das globalisierte
geschäftsmodell steht plötzlich in frage
außen und wirtschaftspolitik wird zum
permanenten krisen management patricia
wiedemeier in den letzten jahren vor
corinna gab es für die deutsche
wirtschaft eigentlich nur eine tendenz
immer mehr immer größer immer höheres
wachstum die globalisierung die
weltweiten verflechtungen machten es
möglich
deutschland lebt sehr sehr stark von der
globalisierung bei dem man kann wirklich
sagen dass unser wohlstand von der
globalisierung abhängig ist mit der
globalisierung gewachsen ist deutschland
ist ein globalisierungsgewinner und
genau aus diesem grund hält der kanzler
an der globalisierung fest die
globalisierung für ihn keine alternative
um es ganz klar zu sagen die die
globalisierung ist ein holzweg sie wird
nicht funktionieren
doch selbst die wirtschaft sieht
inzwischen ein es muss sich etwas ändern
denn die abhängigkeiten nähe zu
deutschland selber besitzt viele
rohstoffe nicht hat zahlreiche
produktionen ausgelagert ins ausland
corona und kriegsbedingt gibt es jetzt
dramatische lieferengpässe man wird
künftig etwas mehr wert legen auf
absicherung gegen störungen das heißt
doch etwas mehr lagerhaltung und
vielleicht nicht nur einen produzenten
haben der wichtige teile liefert sondern
zwei oder drei in verschiedenen ländern
doch die suche nach neuen partnern nach
neuen ländern nicht so einfach sei es in
katar sei es in kanada und neue
lieferanten heißt auch es könnte alles
ähnlich wie beim gas teurer werden
wir werden sicherlich einen wandel
brauchen von einer globalisierung die
kosten getrieben war also nach dem
billigsten gesucht hat hin zu einer
globalisierung die auf nachhaltigkeit
und resilienz achtet aber es dauert
sicher jahre schritt für schritt bei uns
anfangen mit dem weg seidling mit einer
starken kreislaufwirtschaft mit
rohstoffen die bei uns vorhanden sind
und gleichzeitig in der welt uns
wesentlich breiter aufzustellen
es ist vor allem die abhängigkeit von
china die zunehmend sorge bereitet
sollte sich der konflikt mit taiwan
ernsthaft ausweiten dann wäre nicht nur
die amerikanische sondern auch die
europäische und die deutsche wirtschaft
betroffen das zentrale achse auch der
weltwirtschaft us chinesische an die
us-chinesischen positionen sind das was
sozusagen globalisierung zusammen hält
die beziehung wäre zerbrochenes werden
dramatische schock für die
weltwirtschaft das wachstum würde
einbrechen unsicherheit überall
lieferketten werden geschockt der
maritime transport in der region wäre
unterbrochen das weitreichende folgen
dann auch hubert für die
nichtregierungsorganisation
attack ist die globalisierung schon
jetzt krachend gescheitert viele
menschen seien reiche aber noch viel
mehr menschen ärmer geworden was wir
brauchen ist eine ganz andere art von
globalisierung nämlich die
globalisierung von demokratien
globalisierung von menschenrechten und
wir brauchen vor allem
handelsbeziehungen die faire aufgebaut
sind
jetzt die globalisierung gestaltet wurde
war es hier so dass immer die großen
konzerne die starken länder die
handelsbedingungen definiert haben
diktiert haben und schwache länder also
die länder afrikas keine chancen hat auf
eine eigene entwicklung die
globalisierung der vergangenen jahre auf
kosten vieler ärmerer menschen und vor
allem auch der umwelt sie muss wohl neu
gedacht neu definiert werden
viele spitzenleute der politik sind
aktuell im urlaub es wirkt fast so als
wollten sie kollektiv noch mal schnell
kraft tanken bevor eine norm
anstrengender herbst und winter kommt
auch der cdu-außenpolitiker norbert
röttgen ist jetzt aus seinem urlaubsort
bei uns wo er die weltlage weiter
verfolgt nämlich einen guten abend herr
röttgen
einen guten abend herr sievers und ihnen
langsam angst und bange wird
fragezeichen weil unsere welt eben nur
eine bestimmte menge von krisen
gleichzeitig verträgt
angst und bange darf jedenfalls kein
ratgeber sein und es muss uns klar sein
wir können nicht die zahl der
gleichzeitigen krisen und
herausforderungen
bestimmen wir müssen uns klar werden das
ist eine neue gleichzeitigkeit eine
riesige komplexität gibt klimawandel
öffentliche gesundheit pandemie china
russland es ist alles gleichzeitig das
müssen wir lernen es hilft nichts was
muss denn machen was man ganz konkret
röttgen was muss außenpolitik denn jetzt
leisten wir erleben ja im moment eine
deutsche außenministerin die china
heftig kritisiert die sich auch mit dem
türkischen kollegen etwa auf ein podium
stellt und dann offen mit ihm streitet
ist dass die neue taktik für eine neue
zeit
also wir brauchen keine taktik sondern
wir brauchen eine strategie und zwar
eine die vorausschauend ist die sich
damit beschäftigt krisen zu erkennen und
einer der erkennbaren krisen ist ein
militärischer konflikt um taiwan das
keine frage man sollte die ankündigung
des chinesischen parteiführer shipping
ernst nehmen das ist das pflichtprogramm
der kommunistischen partei wenn es dazu
kommen sollte hat das wird ist eine eine
ungekannte escala
ja und darum geräten bleibt man gerade
china eine thema auf jeden fall da reden
wir auch gleich noch mal ganz explizit
darüber ich hatte aber jetzt aber
gefragt wie konkret sich außenpolitik
auch deutsche außenpolitik jetzt
aufzustellen hat wenn wir
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel uns
anschauen die hatte beispielsweise in
china immer eine wirtschaftsdelegation
im schlepptau das war dann so eine art
türöffner besuch für deutsche
investitionen hinter verschlossenen
türen hieß es seien menschenrechte
angesprochen worden so wird es ja in
zukunft nicht mehr gehen ist also etwas
was zum beispiel nancy pelosi jetzt
gemacht hat in taiwan klare signale
setzen ist das der richtige weg
also zum ersten unsere china politik die
industrie exportpolitik ist unsere
handelspolitik die stadt findet unter
ausblendung von geostrategischen und
sicherheitsrisiken ist beendet das ist
vorbei und wir spüren es ja jetzt mit
der abhängigkeit von energie von
russland energie wird zur waffe gemacht
wachstum aus china wird zur waffe
gemacht werden das heißt wir müssen
sicherheit und geo strategie in unser
wirtschaftsmodell in unserer
außenwirtschaft integrieren und rheine
exportpolitik reicht nicht aber was
pelosi gemacht hat das ist symbolpolitik
das ist ein streit anfachen in einer
zeit in der wir genug internationale
spannungen haben ohne dass ein
konstruktiver ertrag er steht der größte
gewinner ist sie empfing das steht vor
einem großen parteikongress er ist
intern unter druck und der nutzt diese
provokation um nationalismus und
militarismus zu führen dass es war ein
sehr teurer besuch der nichts gebracht
hat also symbolismus ist nicht das dafür
brauchen wir brauchen ernsthafte
sicherheitsstrategie und wir können
nicht mehr außenhandel ohne geo
strategie betreiben das müssen wir
deutschen lernen okay sagen sie als
politiker auf der anderen seite stehen
aber die manager die ich zitiere den
immer noch aktuellen vw chef der sagt
die zukunft von volkswagen wird sich auf
dem chinesischen markt entscheiden wir
merken ja aktuell bereits dass wir schon
knapsen werden an den energiepreisen und
der gasknappheit in sachen russland wenn
china jetzt tatsächlich taiwan angreifen
würde könnten wir uns dann sanktionen
gegen china überhaupt leisten
im moment so gut wie nicht was der
vw-chef sagt ist eine betrübliche
aussage wie die zukunft von vw die
zukunft hängt an dem willen und den
machtinteressen eines großen autoritären
staates ich glaube dass das für vw
stimmt wenn es aber eben dazu kommt und
wir zulassen dass das für deutschland
stimmt dann wäre unser ganzes land und
damit auch ein erheblicher weise europa
eben in der gleichen abhängigkeit von
china wie sich vw in diese abhängigkeit
gebracht hat aber sie haben aber es ist
ja das gleiche gilt ja auch für mercedes
das gilt auch für bmw und jetzt immer
nur bei den autofirmen es gilt für viele
maschinenbauer in deutschland am ende
sind das ja
wirtschaftszweige auf die wir alle bauen
dieses land baut in seiner
wirtschaftskraft
und darum sie können auch noch die
chemie industrie und die pharmazeutische
industrie hinzufügen es ist die breite
der deutschen volkswirtschaft und darum
müssen wir jetzt erkennen und lernen aus
der abhängigkeit in einem sektor energie
von russland dass wir eine kurskorrektur
brauchen wir brauchen eine kurskorrektur
in unserem außenhandel weil er uns in
eine abhängigkeit führt führt uns
wirklich hilflos macht in dem fall eines
konfliktes und das müssen wir
korrigieren wir müssen eine neue
außenwirtschafts strategie entwickeln
wir brauchen neue wachstumsfelder wir
können es nicht so treiben lassen wir
sind sonst nicht mehr souverän und
handlungsfähig einzelnen unternehmen
kann das machen aber wenn sich daraus
eine ansteckungsgefahr das ganze land
ergibt und da sehen wir jetzt ist es zu
viel und darum brauchen wir eine
kurskorrektur jetzt haben wir vor den
bisherigen kurs aber ganz gut gelebt
heißt das ganz kurz vielleicht noch herr
röttgen dass das was sie jetzt gerade
vorschlagen am ende dann auch eine
wohlstands frage für uns ist
also es ist definitiv die neue
geopolitische konfliktlage ist für
deutschland speziell eine wohlstands
frage weil wir bislang gelebt haben
unter ausblendung all diese risiken aber
es ist nicht das ende von wohlstand wir
müssen uns anpassen wir müssen innovativ
werden neue wachstumsfelder entwickeln
wir müssen aktiv und pro aktiv werden
das brauchen wir nicht streit rhetorik
nicht symbolismus sondern eine proaktive
strategie gerade auch zur sicherung
unseres wo stand ist aber auch unsere
sicherheit wir müssen aufwachen in
deutschland norbert röttgen cdu
außenpolitiker ich dagegen als herzlich
für das gespräch heute abend ich danke
ihnen dass sie was vielen dank danke wie
mit politischen extremisten umgehen das
ist auch eine frage für die afg und zwar
sowohl was den umgang beziehungsweise
die nähe etwa zum herrscher im kreml
angeht als auch in den eigenen reihen
der präsident des verfassungsschutzes
jedenfalls sieht die extremisten in der
afg gestärkt was parteichefin alice
weiter dazu sagt heute war zdf
sommerinterview mit ihr david gepard hat
die details die art die seit monaten
gespalten bei ihrer haltung zu putins
russland parteichefin weidl verurteilt
im zdf-sommerinterview zwar den angriff
sieht aber eine art mitverantwortung des
westens
die russen haben immer ganz klar und
deutlich gemacht dass sie keine
gegnerische macht in ihrem hinterhof
akzeptieren würden und die ukraine nicht
gleich auf einen neutralen status
gesetzt zu haben das ist der fehler den
der westen sich ankreiden lassen ich
halte es für falsch immer wieder zu
relativieren zu differenzieren bei
fällen wo die lage eindeutig ist und
hier gibt es eindeutig einen
angriffskrieg putins dfb vertreter waren
in den letzten monaten immer wieder mit
rechtfertigung für putins angriffskrieg
aufgefallen hatten teils eins zu eins
kreml propaganda verbreitet etwa dass
russland quasi aus notwehr handele die
amerikaner hätten die ukraine
unterwandert
haben sich wieder ein spalt die durch
die partei beim umgang mit russland und
seit dieser woche auch mit china bezogen
auf den streit über westliche besucher
im demokratischen taiwan hatte
co-parteichef kuba gefordert die
bundesregierung muss die legitimen
sicherheitsinteressen chinas
respektieren unsere aufgabe kann nicht
darin bestehen verständnis für die
kommunistische menschenverachtende
führung in china zu äußern das ist in
der tat unfug ein hang zum autoritären
antiliberalen dna des extremistischen
hügel sinne afd auch deshalb wird seit
märz dieses jahres die gesamtpartei als
verdachtsfall für rechtsextreme
bestrebungen vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet auch ein gericht sah
ausreichende tatsächliche anhaltspunkte
für verfassungsfeindliche bestrebungen
im juni dann wahl eines neuen fdp
vorstands erstmals seit der
neuaufstellung der partei äußert sich
der verfassungsschutz chef und warnt im
zdf nach dem bundesparteitag der afg in
riesa sehen wir eine stärkung der
extremistischen strömungen in der partei
neuen bundesvorstand findet sich kein
dezidierter kritiker des formal
aufgelösten rechtsextremistischen
verdachtsfalls flügel mehr weil
widerspricht greift die behörde an
ein dienst den es sonst nirgends der
verfassungsschutz wie es jetzt politisch
instrumentalisiert um eine
oppositionsparteien noch und nöcher zu
verunglimpfen darum weiß unabhängiges
gericht darauf muss man auch hinweise
ihrer herstellung gesagt der
verfassungsschutz hat ausreichende
tatsächliche anhaltspunkte die afg eine
neue vorsitzende und alte probleme die
haltung zu autoritären staaten und die
frage wie umgehen mit dem rechtsextremen
flügel
die aktuelle lage in der ukraine jetzt
unterhält die welt gerade den atem an
und zwar insbesondere wegen der
situation an europas grösstem
atomkraftwerke ja wieder wurde das
ukrainische atomkraftwerk in fukushima
beschossen und wieder machen sich
russland und die ukraine gegenseitig
dafür verantwortlich bei dem angriff
soll ein lager für abgebrannten
kernbrennstoff getroffen worden seien
zudem seien sensoren zur strahlenmessung
beschädigt worden erst am freitag war
das kraftwerk beschossen worden die
betreiber hatten daraufhin einen reaktor
heruntergefahren
der chef der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde warnte gestern vor
der gefahr einer nuklearkatastrophe
die getreideexporte aus der ukraine
kommen voran vier weitere schiffe haben
am morgen ukrainische häfen verlassen
beladen mit etwa
160.000 tonnen getreide und
sonnenblumenöl sind sie unterwegs in
richtung china türkei und italien
wegen der russischen angriffe waren in
den vergangenen monaten alle
getreideexporte der ukraine aus ihren
schwarz mehr häfen blockiert worden
angesichts der stark gestiegenen
gaspreise warnt der deutsche mieterbund
dass millionen menschen künftig ihre
heizkosten nicht mehr zahlen können
betroffen seien vor allem personen die
knapp oberhalb staatliche
hilfsleistungen liegen erklärte
verbandschef siebenkotten dem
tagesspiegel deshalb müssten
einkommensgrenzen für menschen die
wohngeld beanspruchen können deutlich
erhöht werden forderte er
der us senat hat am abend einem
milliardenschweren maßnahmenpaket der
regierung zugestimmt mit gesetzen zum
klimaschutz und zur sozialpolitik nimmt
ein wichtiges vorhaben von us-präsident
beiden eine entscheidende hürde
vorgesehen sind unter anderem
investitionen von rund 400 milliarden
dollar in den klimaschutz das
repräsentantenhaus muss noch zustimmen
dort haben die demokraten eine knappe
mehrheit
die intendantin des rundfunks
berlin-brandenburg patricia schlesinger
ist mit sofortiger wirkung von ihrem amt
zurückgetreten
hintergrund sind unter anderem vorwürfe
der vetternwirtschaft
schwesinger steht etwa wegen der vergabe
von beraterverträgen in der kritik die
61 jährige bestreitet die vorwürfe am
donnerstag war schlesinger bereits als
ard vorsitzende zurückgetreten
wegen einer möglichen corona welle im
herbst hat bundesgesundheitsminister
lauterbach die ständige impfkommission
dazu aufgefordert ihre empfehlungen zur
vierten impfung anzupassen bisher wird
diese ausschließlich menschen über 70
und einer risikogruppe empfohlen auch
jüngere wollten wissen was sie tun
sollen deshalb sollte es klare ansagen
für jedes alter geben sagte lauterbach
der funke mediengruppe
wenn die gewalt eskaliert zwischen
israel und palästinensischen extremisten
im gazastreifen dann kommt irgendwann
der punkt an dem beide seiten nach
ägypten schauen
das ist meist ein gutes zeichen denn
dort machen sich vermittler bereit um
einen waffenstillstand hinzubekommen
oder zumindest eine waffenruhe so ist es
auch diesmal nach tagelangen schweren
kämpfen und natürlich heißt dass
hoffnung auf das leid und angst aufhören
mögen auf beiden seiten allerdings zeigt
die viel zu lange erfahrung die wir mit
gaza kriegen leider haben das mit zu
einem waffenstillstand wenn er denn
klappt gleichzeitig die uhr zu ticken
beginnt bis es wieder losgeht aus tel
aviv berichtet andreas künast
als tel aviv an diesem abend die sirenen
hört als es sich hunde handys handtücher
schnappt und in die schutzräume sprintet
ist es 21 minuten vor 7 21 minuten vor
beginn der zu dieser zeit angekündigten
waffenruhe das ende eines tages zwischen
neuer hoffnung und neuer gewalt den
süden des gazastreifens traf diesmal die
militärische kraft israels neutralisiert
schreibt das militär auf das foto von
pallett mansur der hier für den
islamischen jihad das kommando hatte bei
den angriffen in rafah werden auch
zivilisten verletzt die palästinenser
melden nicht nur zahlreiche notaufnahmen
sondern auch fünf tote darunter ein kind
der angriff war angst einjagen wir
rannten davon voller panik die frauen
und kinder vor angst fast gelähmt es war
so schlimm ich kann es gar nicht in
worte fassen
trauer und wut auch im norden des gaza
streifen in dschabalia sterben fünf
kinder und ein erwachsener für diese
toten macht israel eine fehlgeleitete
rakete des islamischen jihad
verantwortlich
keine israelische aktionen dieser gegend
zu dieser zeit der islamische dschihad
tötet kinder in gaza
zum beweis veröffentlichte israel dieses
video das den absturz der tödlichen
rakete zeigen soll israelischen
schätzungen zufolge gehen ein drittel
der palästinensischen raketen in gaza
nieder der islamische dschihad feiert an
diesem abend auch nach 19 uhr auf israel
der erste versuch einer waffenruhe
gescheitert der nächste soll halb elf
deutscher zeit beginnen
spirale der gewalt heißt es ja gerne
über das was wir aus dem nahen osten
berichten müssen das klingt erstmal
eingängig übersieht aber dass es eben
kein konflikt auf autopilot ist dass
jede neue eskalation gründe hat
militärische politische manchmal auch
wirtschaftliche und das eben eine
grundlegende lösung fehlt geh mal live
nach tel aviv zu andreas cüppers können
andreas haben denn für dieses mal beide
seiten ihre ziele zumindest vorläufig
erreicht
nein nicht beide seiten ich glaube man
kann sagen dass israel zumindest seine
militärischen ziele im gazastreifen
erreicht hat zum beispiel die tötung der
beiden anführer des islamischen jihad
gestern des kommandeurs für den norden
heute des kommandeurs für den süden ob
der islamische dschihad forderungen
durchsetzen konnte in den verhandlungen
mit ägypten lässt sich jetzt noch nicht
abschätzen dazu wie zum beispiel die
freilassung bestimmter gefangener gehört
aber ihre ziele erreicht hat kaum eine
der mehr als 900 raketen die die
organisation in den vergangenen tagen
auf israel abgefeuert hat und auch in
der konkurrenz zur hamas zur stärksten
kraft im gazastreifen ist diese
zweitstärkste kraft am ende eher
schwächer als am anfang verloren haben
auf jeden fall die menschen im gaza
streifen fast 40 ihr leben und fast alle
ja mal wieder die hoffnung auf
dauerhaften frieden
andreas vielen dank wir bleiben noch
moment bei dir und im nahen osten wo
nichts geht und alles möglich ist gerade
jetzt wenn der konflikt wieder
schlagzeilen macht ist die
widersprüchlichkeit dieser region schwer
zu begreifen und lässt einen
gleichzeitig nicht mehr los andreas
künast und das team des zdf studios
nehmen uns mit an einen ort der einmalig
ist auf dieser welt der so
lebensfeindlich daherkommt und
gleichzeitig so verletzlich ist wo man
still wird vor staunen und gleichzeitig
beginnen darf zu träumen
es ist noch nicht sechs es ist noch
nicht zu heiß und es ist noch nicht klar
ob dieser morgen hält was sich das team
von ihm verspricht sie haben respekt vor
diesem ganz speziellen ort vor den
mörderischen temperaturen vor der
mörderischen sonne und vor dem meer das
siegerlied landau mehr nennt ihr totes
meer nur dass es heute ein klein
bisschen lebendig ist wellen sind sehr
selten für die gegend und sehr schlecht
für die kunst
sehen sie dass eine objekt da das kleine
ballerina kleid das seil ist ab durch
den wind wir haben heute die sos mission
es zu retten
das ballerina kleid hat sie galt vor
vier wochen ins tote meer gehängt und
dann das wasser einfach machen lassen
bei mehr als 30 prozent salzgehalt lebt
kein fisch lebt keine pflanze in dieser
see sondern nur ihre kunst aus salz und
auszeit entstehen landau skulpturen die
wird gut die bleibt
das problem neid kann gesichert aber
nicht gerettet werden landes plastiken
sind genau so zerbrechlich wie das meer
das sie formt dass dieses berühmte
wasser indem man nicht schwimmt sondern
schwebt von monat zu monat weniger wird
dass der pegel beängstigend sinkt auch
darauf sollen landes arbeiten aufmerksam
machen
sogar der landstreifen von dem aus wir
arbeiten in früheren jahren war er weg
jetzt ist er da die veränderungen gehen
sehr schnell
the burning sea das brennende mehr heißt
die ausstellung die sieger die landau
gerade für das israel museum in
jerusalem vorbereitet liebhaber zahlen
fünf bis sechsstellige summen für eine
echte landau die immer seit sich immer
unwirklich und wie alles in israel immer
auch politisch ist
wir werden keine normalität haben ohne
frieden zu haben das tote meer ist
eigentlich eine chance es könnte seine
anlieger die jordania die palästinenser
und die israelis verbinden zum nutzen
einer vierten partei die rettung und
zusammenarbeit braucht zum nutzen des
meers selbst
es ist das besondere an diesem mehr dass
es so heiß so beißend so tot ist und es
ist das besondere an diesem team dass es
aus dem toten meer etwas lebendiges
herausholt
kristallisierte kunst die uns auch klar
machen soll das tote meer stirbt das ist
kein spruch das ist die realität
jetzt hier in der sendung der sport und
nochmal johanna und da beginnen wir mit
der fußball bundesliga im ersten
sonntagsspiel der saison trafen heute
der vfb stuttgart und rb leipzig
aufeinander und trennten sich 1 zu 1 und
der erste fc köln siegte gegen schalke
04 mit 3 zu 1
und dann stehen noch zwei prominente
wechsel in der bundesliga an laut
übereinstimmenden medienberichten soll
die rückkehr von nationalspieler timo
werner vom fc chelsea zu rb leipzig kurz
bevorstehen und außerdem gibt es eine
mündliche einigung über den wechsel von
antoni modells zum ersten fc vom ersten
fc köln zu borussia dortmund
bei der dressur em im dänischen herning
muss sich die neu formierte deutsche
mannschaft mit bronze begnügen
erst zum dritten mal in der geschichte
geht die goldmedaille damit nicht an
deutschland das beste deutsche
einzelergebnis lieferte isabell werth
auf platz fünf gastgeber dänemark stand
am ende ganz oben auf dem treppchen
silber ging an großbritannien das
war unsere welt an diesem sonntag was
wir zu erwarten haben in der kommenden
woche dafür gibt es den heute journal
ausblick heute von christian kirsch
[Musik]
bleibt gerhard schröder mitglied der spd
am montag will die schiedskommission des
zuständigen spd unterbezirks in hannover
ihre entscheidung bekanntgeben 17
anträge aus verschiedenen kreisverbänden
und ortsvereinen fordern den ausschluss
des ex kanzlers und ehemalige
parteichefs aus der spd
hoher besuch in der zentrale des
deutschen fußball bundes in frankfurt
für dienstag hat sich bundeskanzler
scholz angekündigt auf der themenliste
die forderung nach gleicher bezahlung
von männern und frauen im profifußball
durch den erfolg der frauen bei der em
hatte der ruf nach equal pay 90 arten
trauerfeier in hamburg am mittwoch
gedenkt fußball-deutschland im stadion
des hsv seiner sport legende uwe seeler
der ehemalige nationalspieler war ende
juli im alter von 85 jahren gestorben
auch bundeskanzler scholz will an der
gedenkfeier für seeler teilnehmen
ab freitag jährt sich zum zwanzigsten
mal das katastrophale hochwasser entlang
der elbe anfang august 2002 waren dort
nach extremen regenfällen bäche seen und
flüsse über die ufer getreten mindestens
45 tote allein in deutschland schäden
über neun milliarden euro
seither werden immer wieder stimmen laut
die fordern die bebauung entlang der
gewässer zu begrenzen und flüssen mehr
raum für überflutung zu geben
und jetzt noch ein ausblick und zwar
aufs wetter morgen ziehen im norden
zeitweise dichtere wolken durch sonst
herrscht meist ruhiges wetter weiterhin
ist es zu trocken mit hoher
waldbrandgefahr höchste temperaturen
zwischen 21 und 32 grad auch in den
nächsten tagen herrscht trockenes und
überwiegend sonniges wetter 21 bis 34
grad
sowie zwei hier sagen danke für ihr
interesse im namen des gesamten
heute-journal teams ab morgen sind an
dieser stelle marietta slomka und heinz
wolf für sie da und ihnen jetzt noch
einen schönen abend
[Musik]